back she brings her Southern Charm to
Beverly Hills says bless your heart but
in the most fashionable way and I really
hope that she approves of my leather
outfit today please welcome to the show
of The Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
Sutton Strack so great to see you son
nice to see you too no I'm glad we're
both we're twins yes we've got leather
going I was a little nervous because
Crystal's leather pants were such a big
topic and funny because we we will never
ever forget that and now we'd laugh at
it well it's just a joke now but it was
very intense
in the moment it definitely was yes
we're both I think now we're scared to
wear leather pants and I wear leather
pants all the time and I got them in my
store
it's just funny well speaking of your
story you welcome us into your boutique
throughout the show it's so fun to see
you're kind of the resident fashionista
but you're also celebrating fashion
while you're out here in Las Vegas tell
me what you're up to what your new
Endeavor is yeah so um I've attended the
Manifest conference and it was really
cool because it's about the future of
like how we're going to get Goods sent
to our house and it's unbelievable
um it's sort of like the Jetsons it's
truly unreal so um it was fun to see and
so it's great to be in Vegas yeah we're
so happy to have you here and I love
just following along with all of your
fashion and your outfits on every
episode is that so fun for you to get to
dress up and wear something fun every
time yeah you know some days it's fun
and Sunday so I'm like oh what am I
gonna wear so you know I think we all
kind of struggle with that every day
um but I love it it's you know what I do
yeah we're seeing some photos of your
your different pieces and I love to hear
that you say sometimes you don't even
know what to wear because look at all
these photos one is better than the next
I love the pajamas do you like to be
comfy and cozy is that why you designed
those yeah I think during pandemic we
all kind of um got in pajamas I started
with cashmere I love cashmere this is my
cashmere dress I love it
um I thought all right I'm going to do
my own line let's do cashmere because I
wear cashmere a lot and the cashmere
comes from the
the
yarn comes from Italy and then we make
it in LA my pajamas we make in La my
teas we make in La so um that was really
important to me and I've got a second
Endeavor now that's all my black label I
have a second label it's a green label
and it's a circular fashion line
um so that's how we're going to save the
Earth and it's a remanufactured
relabeled line so we're combining the
two and I'm starting with betting I love
bedding and pajamas and Cashmere they
kind of they all three go together so I
think it's going to be fun and I'm
really excited about it I like that you
like comfy remember that episode when
the grass was muddy and you were giving
everyone like slippers and
like we fixed my yard so it doesn't do
that anymore okay God because it's been
raining so much in L.A yeah
I have no more bottles and no more
mudslides in my yard okay good well I
know that you can't say much about
what's coming up next but let's take it
back a little bit on the show I love
that you have brought your Southern
Flair they needed a little bit of that
but let's talk about the show is all
everyone should have a southern fish
I need you in my life I need a southern
friend but what I love about this show
you know someone's always throwing shade
left and right yeah would you say the
way that it's usually shade is hey
you're bringing that southern Flair like
we said is it a little different from
the south to Beverly Hills of how people
kind of argue and throw that shade at
each other well yeah I mean you know I
think when I say something I'm kind of
being funny yeah and they're not
that's an or they take my shade as real
serious right and I you know it's not
supposed to be like that yeah I don't
know I think growing up at my house you
you had to have kind of thick skin and
so I that's how I treat the tables that
where we are and it backfires on me
quite often but it seems like by the end
of each season everyone kind of comes
around and knows what you were trying to
say for the most part right yeah I mean
you know I have to explain myself kind
of over and over and um you know at the
end hopefully we all come together
because we have to right we're in this
all as one and it's it's kind of a
family a very dysfunctional family but a
family not aren't they all right and
when we started this interview before we
showed a clip of you I love the taglines
it's everyone's favorite thing the last
one if you want to see it at my table
you better mind your manners right yeah
so I came up with my own tagline can you
tell me what you think I wrote it down
okay tell me if this would make the cut
okay okay I'm from Vegas so we're
playing into that so the only sin this
Vegas girl commits is being too
glamorous
I like it she doesn't approve I like it
do you have another suggestions I'm
putting you on the spot you know it's
you have to do it with like the only
you've got to like do the hip thing and
then yeah okay can I try it again
okay here we go yeah the only sin this
Vegas girl commits is being too
glamorous I'll see there you go is that
better yeah okay
um really quickly I have to ask you
because I'm always so curious about this
the the table seatings and the
assignments it's always a big thing is
that is that really important to you
okay with parties the fir my first
season it was just a big table yeah and
I didn't know where to sit
and so all right where what's going on
and so I introduced I think to the world
place card seriously I bet they went out
of Now everywhere I wish I hadn't done
that because now everybody's using Place
cards they're like oh I really didn't
want to sit next to her and they you
know because you can use it to your
advantage yes or no so I'm like oh gosh
I never should have done Place cards
ever but you know I think everybody
should have Place cards at their table
it's important it is important it is it
makes your guests feel at ease it's
better with you and so if I'm ever at a
dinner party with you I am requesting my
name plate be next year okay yes yes yes
and thank you so much for stopping by we
always love seeing out here in Vegas and
hopefully we'll see you in Beverly Hills
again but I know your lips are sealed
right now so thanks again here things
are turning around okay we'll leave it
at that